Nos meilleures innovations sont la création de marques
qui peuvent changer notre vie
et refléter le type de monde dans lequel nous voulons vivre.
En novembre 2016,
Krista Suh, Jayna Zweiman et Kat Coyle
ont créé un bonnet à porter pour la marche des femmes à Washington.
(Applaudissements)
C'était le lendemain de l'inauguration du président.
Deux mois plus tard, le 21 janvier 2017,
des millions de personnes dans le monde ont porté le bonnet rose tricoté
en soutien à la marche des femmes sur tous les continents.
Ce bonnet n'a pas été créé pour un bénéfice financier.
Comme nos symboles religieux créé il y a des milliers d'années,
ce bonnet a été créé par des gens, pour les gens,
pour servir à ce que je crois être le plus grand atout de l'image de marque :
unir les gens dans l'expression
d'idéaux partagés.
Le bonnet rose est devenu le signe d'un mouvement.
En très peu de temps, en deux mois,
il était devenu reconnaissable dans le monde entier.
Il a permis de relier un public d'une façon inédite.
C'est une marque,
mais c'est bien plus que ça.
Aujourd'hui, le bonnet rose est la preuve
que l'image de marque n'est pas qu'un outil du capitalisme.
L'image de marque est la manifestation profonde de l'esprit humain.
La situation de l'image de marque a toujours reflété celle de notre culture.
C'est notre responsabilité
de continuer à exploiter la capacité démocratique de l'image de marque
et c'est notre responsabilité
de créer une culture qui reflète
et honore
le type de monde dans lequel nous voulons vivre.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)